Transcription: Odei Olaizola
Relecteur: eric vautier
Au fil du temps, j’ai constaté que
la cohésion et le multiculturalisme
n’ont pas toujours été d’un commun accord
en ce qui concerne
les rapports entre les êtres humains.
En d’autres termes, Dame Cohésion
et Sieur Multiculturalisme
que j’incarne ce soir
n’ont pas toujours vécu en harmonie.
Pourquoi je le dis ?
Car j’ai fait le tour des grandes
aires culturelles du Cameroun.
J’ai voyagé à travers les livres,
à travers la télé.
J’ai même effectué des déplacements
dans d’autres régions.
Et à chaque fois,
je me suis retrouvé en train
de partir d’un espace à un autre
du fait de mes insatisfactions multiples.
Je voulais un endroit tranquille
pour me poser,
un endroit tranquille
pour entretenir des relations saines
avec d’autres personnes comme moi.
Mais je me retrouvais
toujours en déplacement.
Alors pour commencer,
j’ai posé mes valises
dans l’aire côtière,
au littoral du pays.
Il y avait une forte présence en eau.
Des cantons, des noblesses.
Là-bas, le roi était respecté
et vénéré de tous.
J’ai même eu la chance de goûter
au ndolè, un plat local de la région.
Mais le seul problème,
c’est qu’il y avait trop de politique.
La politique avait pris
le dessus sur la bonté.
Marquée par le seul fait
que chacun voulait sa part du gibier.
Même moi, Sieur Multiculturalisme,
je n’étais que là pour les non-partisans.
Ne pouvant supporter
cet état de discrimination politique,
j’ai déménagé
vers une autre aire culturelle.
J’ai posé mes valises
dans la zone Gras-filds.
Les gens de là-bas accordaient
beaucoup d’importance à la terre.
Pour eux, la terre ne trahissait jamais.
Ils y cultivaient, y investissaient,
se reproduisaient,
se multipliaient à la vitesse de l’éclair.
Le taro était toujours mis en avant
et à l’honneur dans les cérémonies.
Un mets local également.
Mais le seul problème,
c’est qu’ils ne se comprenaient pas.
Je vous explique.
Imaginez que je sois un Gras-filds.
J’ai un voisin Gras-filds.
Il y a une route
qui sépare nos deux maisons.
On est presque de la même ethnie.
Mais si je traverse pour aller chez lui,
on ne se comprend plus.
Très paradoxal, très compliqué.
Alors j’ai décidé de me déplacer
une fois de plus vers la zone Béti.
Au sud du pays.
Et au centre également.
Là-bas, l’air était très agréable.
Le climat impeccable.
Je pensais avoir trouvé la terre promise.
J’ai même eu la chance de me relaxer
devant un bon plat d’okok.
Un mets local également.
Mais à ma grande surprise,
le respect avait perdu sa valeur.
Même dire bonjour était un problème.
Chacun poursuivait ses propres objectifs.
Le tout marqué par des querelles
aux allures tribales.
Rabaissant les plus faibles
au profit des plus forts.
Moi, Sieur Culturalisme,
je ne pouvais pas supporter ça.
Alors, une fois de plus,
je suis parti vers la zone
soudano-sahélienne au septentrion du pays.
Mais avant ça, j’ai fait mes recherches.
La Présidence de la République du Cameroun
déclare qu’il y a environ
240 ethnies dans ce pays.
Et cette diversité culturelle
représente en fait une tour de Babel.
Pour la petite histoire, la tour de Babel,
selon la Bible.
Les hommes de Babylone ont décidé
de construire une tour
qui arriverait au ciel.
Pourtant, ils parlaient
tous la même langue.
Ils voulaient entrer
discrètement au paradis.
Bien évidemment,
Dieu, mécontent de leur orgueil,
les punit en leur faisant parler
des langues différentes.
Alors ils se dispersèrent sur la Terre
et formèrent les différents peuples.
Mais avant de continuer, je voudrais vous
soumettre à un jeu de logique.
On se rend compte
que le multiculturalisme est la punition
que Dieu a décidé d’infliger aux hommes.
Vu que j’incarne
le multiculturalisme ce soir,
je suis la punition
que Dieu a décidé de vous infliger.
J’ai percé depuis la Bible, je suis
très célèbre et comme on dit au pays :
[Langue étrangère]
depuis longtemps.
Mais ce qui me fait mal
dans cette histoire,
c’est que c’est lorsque la guerre a éclaté
au nord-ouest et au sud-ouest
qu’ils se sont souvenus
que moi, j’existais.
Ils m’ont enseveli dans les dictionnaires
pour ensuite me ressusciter
en espérant que tout irait mieux.
On parle de cohésion,
de multiculturalisme, de bilinguisme.
Mais la situation ne s’améliore pas.
En tout cas, en attendant
que ça aille bien,
moi, je m’éclate.
Je suis célèbre ; je ne me plains pas.
Alors je poursuis mon périple et j’arrive
dans la zone soudano-sahélienne,
au septentrion du pays.
Et à mes débuts en 2013,
lorsque je descends,
la chaleur m’accueille.
Je vous assure, en 2000, j’ai bronzé.
J’ai même été presque tenté
de prendre le prochain bus pour fuir.
Mais mon for intérieur
m’a dit : « Non. Reste. »
Lorsque j’arrive dans la communauté
où je suis actuellement,
de passage,
tout le monde comprend
que vous êtes nouveau.
Un voisin m’a personnellement approché.
Au lieu de me souhaiter la bienvenue,
comme il est de coutume.
en langue locale, [Langue étrangère],
il m’a plutôt demandé :
[Langue étrangère]
Je vous assure, j’étais sidéré.
J’ai eu du mal à m’intégrer
parmi les hommes de cette aire
du fait qu’ils étaient repliés sur eux
et marchaient par affinités.
La langue parlée n’était ni le français,
ni l’anglais, mais le fulfulde,
une langue locale.
Quand j’allais faire mes courses,
les prix avaient tendance à augmenter
car je ne connaissais pas.
Lorsque les vendeuses me voyaient arriver,
au loin, murmuraient souvent entre elles :
[Langue étrangère]
Comme pour dire : « Le voilà qui arrive. »
On vous indexe de partout.
À l’école, la solitude était
parfois mon meilleur ami
et c’est à cet instant
que Dame Cohésion m’a approché
et elle m’a fait comprendre
que je devais me résigner.
Pourquoi me résigner ?
Parce qu'il faut arrêter de fuir.
Si, souvent, on se trouve
seul avec nos problèmes,
c’est parce que souvent le problème,
c’est nous-même.
Alors j'ai pris sur moi.
J’ai intégré Dame cohésion dans ma vie,
et je vous assure,
en neuf ans d’expérience, aujourd’hui,
je suis un jeune homme très comblé.
Aujourd’hui,
quand j’arrive dans une maison,
il est plus simple pour moi
de dire : « As-salamu alaykum »
pour dire « Bonjour ».
Je suis à l’aise avec les plats
locaux comme le couscous
accompagné du tasmahan,
du foléré, même du koun’nou.
Essayez, c’est très bon.
Pour des besoins économiques,
j’ai appris la culture des céréales,
des arachides, des oignons, du sorgho.
J’ai appris à parler la langue locale
qu’est le fulfulde.
Mais le plus important dans l’histoire,
c’est que, vu qu’aujourd’hui on me confond
aux Soudano-sahéliens,
aux ressortissants du septentrion -
voyez par vous-même -
je peux désormais devenir berger -
ouais - et épouser une Adja.
Très important.
Une Aminatou, Afsatou,
en tout cas celle que je trouverai.
Peut-être.
Auguste auditoire,
peu importe de là où nous venons.
Peu importe
notre aire culturelle d’origine,
il est de notre devoir
de trouver l’équilibre,
l’équilibre parfait,
de façon à créer une alchimie
qui nous permette de nous supporter
les uns les autres, de vivre ensemble.
Pourquoi ne pas nous comprendre ?
Pourquoi être égoïste ?
Pourquoi ne pas respecter l’autre ?
Pourquoi se replier sur soi ?
Je pense que si tout le monde comprenait
le sens du mot [Langue étrangère]
pour dire « Bienvenue »,
si tout le monde comprenait
le sens de la phrase : [Langue étrangère]
pour dire « Je t’aime »,
si tout le monde apprenait
à vivre ensemble
et à se fondre dans la masse,
comme le souhaite l’abbé Jean-Marie Bodo,
si on inculquait
et enseignait nos origines
dans les écoles à nos petits frères,
à nos enfants, à notre prochain,
je suis sûr que Dame Cohésion
serait la femme la plus heureuse du monde.
Moi-même qui incarne
le multiculturalisme ce soir,
je suis un ressortissant de la zone Béti,
je suis du Centre Cameroun,
je suis un Éton fini.
Mais moi, Dame Cohésion,
je l’ai intégrée dans ma vie,
je l’ai courtisée, je l’ai draguée.
L’alliance que je porte ce soir est le
symbole de notre union avec Dame Cohésion.
Et je vous assure que je suis
un jeune homme très comblé.
L’harmonie, si on intégrait
Dame Cohésion dans nos vies,
ne serait plus une utopie
mais une réalité.
Voyez-vous ce soir, avant de sortir,
ce matin, Dame Cohésion,
en très charmante épouse, m’a dit :
« Mon chéri, vu que ce soir tu seras
devant un auditoire,
j’aimerais que tu te vêtisses comme un
digne fils de [Langue étrangère]. »
Et voyez vous-même le résultat.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, en l’honneur de cette
mirobolante femme qu’est Dame Cohésion,
en l’honneur du multiculturalisme
que j’incarne ce soir,
je vous dis : « A la vie, à l’amour. »
Je suis persuadé que si on intégrait
les valeurs de cohésion
et de multiculturalisme dans nos vies,
le Cameroun n’en serait
que plus fort, un et indivisible.
Vive la République du Cameroun.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)